Well. Well, well go to your mom's house
Christina.
Wow.
Y'All were just blessed.
Holy smokes.
What came up here
home all
along here.
Pretty good, Huh? Oh good. Wow.
Gotcha.
Uh, it was guy Higgins. Jeff
Glass. Well that's great.
Apropos hour week cause we've been singing
the last glass song over and over in
the last one. We can't stop
singing it. The song was,
so we're talking about it on three 75.
That one was excellent too. It's glass.
Let's glass.
That was fine.
Yeah.
Which um,
this glass I'll go to all
the moves were his three 75.
So funny. So good. Where does
that, did you, did you steal it?
I bought it in my pocket. You put in
your pocket, put it in my buckles here.
A downloads three 75.
There it is.
Um, replace it. There
you go. Hmm. There it is.
So it was there and I didn't see it here.
Is this a song?
It's a very cold day today.
46 which can
go the Moose.
Let's
go ahead and
pick out a moose.
That's Joseph Gee. Wow. Good work.
Yeah, that's glass to Greg Glass.
It's so it's just glass and it's such
a great phenomenon because now it's
replaced. Chillin. Yeah.
People say I'm just glassing what's glass?
It's glass.
Here we go.
Yeah.
After the first exercise that you want
to do after dislocated your shoulder and
after you've been mobilized,
it is,
you're gonna do this some range of
motion and the range of motion you do.
It's just up to 140 degrees of collection,
which is like how the Hitler
just 40 degrees of external rotation.
Huh?
Don't bring anyone mothers. Well, no,
go to your mom's house.
She,
Christina.
Okay.
Um, I don't know why that
sounds distorted. Yeah, it
doesn't sound good. I know,
but I don't know why. Well, we'll fix it.
I'll put that on my list of things. Well,
can't blue band figure it out?
No, he's not an audio guy. Oh,
you said that because it
was a copy of now it's not.
Now this is the original song. Yeah. Then
I don't, I don't know. I don't know why.
I feel like, cause it's going,
this must be like, I dunno,
some setting or something, something
going through that board. I don't know.
Is it volume too high somewhere?
No, because it wasn't too high.
It just was super distorted.
Yeah. It's really weird. I Dunno.
Well here come the emails. Here's
what's wrong. Oh, I love watching.
People are going to tell me right
now. Oh No, no. Cause it's always, um,
like when something goes wrong
audio wise, yeah. People go, um,
uh, you know, you get like, like
when there was the, um, remember the,
we had the, the old
monitor here, I got like a
hundred emails and it's all like one
guy was like probably that you're htmi
cable is in plugged in all the way.
I know that sounds silly that you should
try it. And then the next guy goes,
do you have this input? Do you have
this output? Do you have the setting?
It's not that,
it's not like everyone tells
you a different thing that
makes you really upset,
you know? No, it doesn't
make me upset. It's, um,
it ends up being like they ended up
proposing 50 different things that can be,
so what'll happen is that sounds a
store did that someone's going to be,
it's this channel. It's this cable. Yeah.
It's this thing is this dial. It's, it's,
it's going to be 50 different suggestions.
I'm saying.
No one can know without being here
what the actual problem is. You know,
luckily we have the Hitler
therapist to help us. So this guy,
um, I dunno, this is just
what he does. He's a, he's,
I like how these guys
introduce themselves. I don't
know if you saw this or not,
but this is how they entered it.
Hi, Bob Schroth physical therapist,
Brad Height and physical therapist.
Together we are the most famous physical
therapist. I'm here. No. All right, Brad.
Today we're talking about top three
exercises that you want to do after just
okay.
In your shoulder.
No, I saw that and I go, is
that accurate? And then I go,
I actually can't dispute that.
I don't know who the most famous,
maybe they are the most famous on the
Internet. Yeah. Are they don't know.
But they're exactly the coolest
that you can claim to be. Sure.
We're the most famous,
hi Bob Schrider physical therapist.
Together we are the most famous physical
therapist. I'm the there. All right, Brad,
today we're talking about top three
exercises that you want to do after just
okay.
In your shoulder.
So Bob and a fucking whatever his name,
they're the most famous
physical therapist. Yeah.
Can we claim that we're the
most famous fart therapists.
Therapists. Uh Huh. Yeah. You think
more than anybody on the Internet,
I think were the most 40 and a
shitty show on the podcast world.
I definitely wear the shittiest
show on the Internet. Yeah.
What can I see that guy's reaction again?
The guy goes,
you just give like a hail Hitler
and the other guy was like, Yup,
try it after the first exercise that
you want to do after dislocated your
shoulder and after you've been mobilized
it cause you're gonna do some range of
motion. Okay. Like how the
range of motion you do.
It's just up to 140 degrees of flection,
which is like how the Hitler,
you can do just 40 degrees
of external rotation.
[inaudible] just like roll with it.
We have it dropped
blue ban and anticipating the
needs. Oh, I love that. Good job.
Which is like how the hit an artery.
Yeah. Interesting. But what I guess, what
else would you call? That's true. Yeah.
Move.
You know, I think if you're
thinking with your brain, you just,
it's just funny that like,
I don't know if for the guy that I'm is
the most famous physical therapist on
the Internet,
I don't know if you realize what you're
doing when you put that on the Internet,
like you're putting, you're
putting yourself saying,
Heil Hitler on the Internet.
Let me know what's going to
come to that perfect gift.
A little Photoshop stuff's going to start
your, uh, your outfit's going to change.
First of all, familiar with swaps. It
goes, but they're going to be all over
the other guys like you are.
That's the way to do it.
You got a Heil Hitler and you know that.
That's what he says in
our private sessions too.
If you want that elbow to
heal a dislocated shoulder,
do it Tom. You do it.
You've been doing it.
No, I'm making sure that my dislocated
shoulder is back in shape. Yeah,
there you go. It feels
good. Can you lend a now?
I didn't say
I know.
Let's say they called these niggas
always. Yeah, always setting
me up. I'm not setting you up.
Okay,
interesting.
We should bring this up.
So remember last week I put out a call
to our English or anybody in the United
Kingdom to let us know if they still say
fags, right. For cigarettes. Someone, uh,
Lee writes in, I'm writing
to confirm that. Yes,
we still call cigarettes fags. Quote,
can I bum a fag off you translates to,
can I have one of your cigarettes?
I haven't actually,
I haven't actual fag as a friend.
The other day I asked if I could bum
one of his fags. He was fine with that.
No confusion.
He gave me a cigarette.
Interesting. There you go. So it was,
I held that position that it
wouldn't change that, that slide.
So I'm challenged. Yeah. Okay. Consensus
is I, it's unchallenged because,
but they also, they don't say he's a
fag. She's a fag or something like that.
Right.
Okay.
I was waiting for this and I'm
surprised it took this long
show up.
So if we could review real quick,
where is this photo even from? That
looks like it might be from the, uh,
that show that those two put on a
couple. Oh, the super serious show.
Super serious picture. Um,
and so a good one for a while,
I've been suggesting a hairstyle
or Christina to stand out,
to stand out from the rest,
stand out from the crowd.
And I know that she's been developing
this hour and you know, working on,
on getting an hour shot.
And I go, man, how about,
how about for the special than a year? No,
I know you're going to end up shooting.
Yeah. You do something that really pops
like to the crap, right? You're scrolling
through. Well, who specialists
that I watch and then,
and then you land on this. Imagine
you're, you're paging through, okay,
who do I watch? Who Do I watch?
And this is the cover art.
Tell me you're not clicking play well.
What's the title?
The title is Farc Shit.
Ah,
no. You know, I look like
their Benjamin Franklin.
You do look like Benjamin
Franklin. Yeah. Kind of similar.
He did kind of, yeah. Yeah. Interesting.
The coloring and the expression.
So would it be electricity please?
That'd be the name of your special.
Yeah. Oh, how about I'm electric.
Okay. Look at that picture. That right
here. It says I'm, and here's the,
now for the people listening,
we're looking at,
unfortunately it's Photoshop
that I wish it were real,
but it is the skull at style that I was
encouraging you where there's no hair on
top. It's completely shaped, but
on the side, your full length,
and you have an expression that says,
I got something to say or something
interesting going on. What?
Anything married just fine.
I think it's boring.
And then I get to see
a nice picture of me.
Tell me what's wrong with standing
out with something like this.
You know right now I go, Oh, you got a
nice head of hair, so right here I go,
whoa. Plus, then you're going to be
like just another female comic, right.
She talking about her period. I don't want
to hear that, but this chick has shit.
This is raw. This chick's
a little out there. Yeah.
I mean I wouldn't even need to put
caution tape over the over my mouth and
what's already there. The
caution tape is, is, is,
is there without being that I don't
even need like a comedy shirt.
Flames on it. Yup. It's a really nice
look. Thank you, Tom. You're welcome.
I'm glad that you finally could see why
I've been, sometimes we'll be married.
You, I swear to God, I remember I
was talking about this yesterday.
We were sitting in the nursery with our
son was one year old now who is just
winding down for the night and you're
sitting in your robe and your dad boxers
and your slips slips and it just a
filthy shirt and your legs are open.
You're sitting in the one proper chair.
I'm sitting on the fork chair and
you're farting and you're, you know,
your guts are hanging out and you go,
who could meet married to you?
I was like a lot of people when
you were like, no, it Kinda,
here's why a lot of husbands fart.
Burb make photoshops of their wife with
a skullet but very few husbands really
unleashed with the fury that you do.
Like who of your friends that are married?
Yeah.
Ha.
Like who unloads as hard as you do
on their wife in terms of like the,
the burbs, the farts, the spread.
You spread your ass cheeks
and Fart. Oh, you did this,
you got it from the dinner table.
And our kid and I were sitting there,
you bent over,
you put your hands on the table and you
bent over and you went and then you,
you farted as you stood up. Yeah. Do you
think a lot of men do that? I think so.
Yeah. Well wait, why did,
I don't think many do,
but many don't do that because they
want to be seen as sexually exciting.
We're talking about Ku
Gaucher savage to their wife,
and then we agreed that Bert,
definitely,
that's true that Burt takes it
to that level. Well, what you,
the stories you've told me
it's pretty heinous. Yeah, no,
I know that he clips his fingernails
and then puts them on a piece of scotch
tape and the tape. Some under a
coffee to coffee table. Yeah. Raw.
That's Herenton told me about one
time he was toying with his asshole.
I don't like the story at all. Oh my
God. And laying in bed and was like,
what's that smell? So she was like, this
smells like garbage. And then he was like,
oh my God, could you now that's
really vulgar. Like that's, that's,
I don't care if I ever get
laid again. It was bart. Yeah.
But most of my friends, you're right,
they do dial it back a little bit.
They dial it back. Why do
you think that is? I mean,
it depends on which friend
you're talking about.
Some of them just have different,
some of them,
their wives will fucking kill them. Yeah.
Yeah. But you know, that's what I mean.
We get emails from people
that owe me and my, you know,
my spouse or like you and this and that.
So we have people that definitely the
people only know the the show version,
which is not far from the real version,
but I'm saying that they don't actually
get to see you in your boxers with your
nuts hanging out and not only that,
modeling some pretty great behavior
for our one year old. Oh yeah,
he's really going to, because
it's, it's in high gear now.
He's waving hi and I'm laughing a lot now.
The little jokes that we have and it's
coming where he's going to start ripping
him and then laughing and then
wanting to be like, oh shit.
Oh we have to pick up poop word.
We've been talking about that.
That's the whole thing is
when you have a one year old,
you start thinking about potty
training's coming down the line.
I've been reading in a book about infant
psychology that the way to lead into
potty training is you come up with a
word that signifies what's happening very
early and you don't make
a big deal out of it.
So when you say that he's pushing out one,
because our son grunts went out today,
he got on all fours and grunted went
out. It was gnarly. And you're like,
well what do we call that? Do we say, Hey,
are you making a Kaka Booboo,
booboo?
Or we thought Megan
Brown Brown since that's,
but then you think about him
in school being like, teacher,
I got to make a brown or mommy,
I got to go make a brown.
Actually thought today I
realized if he can say dump,
um,
because
I would love to hear a child,
Yo, I got to take his job.
Like it's cause it's not actually crude.
It's not a curse.
No. Yeah, I have to dump. I have to take,
or do we teach them the whole phrase?
Yeah.
Teacher,
I gotta take a dump,
excuse me.
And he's like,
I'm going to dump right now
if I don't get to a toilet,
here's what's going to make us laugh more.
Because you have to think about how
long it's going to take to toilet.
Train takes months.
Oh dump would make me laugh.
Brown's also fun.
Yeah.
I got to make Brown and then we
can teach them brown and yellow.
Do you have to make yellow too or
Brown? Is it yellow and Brown? Yeah.
Now we go with dump.
He talking about this size.
I had a big dump.
Right then what do we go with for PG?
Do we say then like peachy. Peachy? Yeah.
Yeah I dunno.
It's interesting.
That's Hungarian too.
Well you say peachy.
Peachy only the same say in Hungarian.
I like,
well it's for Nina for me right now I've,
I've narrowed it down to making a brown.
I got to make Brown.
Yeah or taking you down.
It's funny making Brown is one of
those that he can get away with it more
because he's so small that people
won't think that it's us teaching.
Also figure out like it's
going to be an extra beat
cause no one else will
say it, right? Like Brown,
Brown. And they're like, oh, okay.
By the way, this was saying, you know,
make a brown dad.
I haven't make a brown.
I gotta make a brand. My Dad, I'm
done. Browning come white meat. Wow.
That's going to be fun. I can't wait for
him to start saying this kind of stuff.
Do you know, um, well,
glass was quest. Let's go.
Somebody sent this,
uh,
this video is a Hungarian
guy. Oh, I saw that.
I was watching him watch it part.
It's really colorful. Is it?
Will you explain what's going on?
I'm trying,
I'm trying to wrap my brain
around how hateful it shit
is. Is it really bad? Yeah.
Okay. Well, a lot of the
stuff you hear Your Dad,
my dad sang and Hungarian
growing up like this one.
Where's he,
those are immigrants that he's running.
They're
called the tig and are Gypsies.
He's
right. So there's like, these are
refugees and cheese and he's a,
he's a hung go. Yeah. What was he saying
back there? Well, he's saying, you know,
core devine. Yeah, I'd
get the fuck out of my,
he was actually trying to teach and
he's trying to hit them. Yup. Yup.
Well they'll secret some
Hungarians are very racist. Yeah.
I wonder if just a little,
they have travel. Travel
did play it again.
I thought he said Midland Mamane.
Oh,
he's saying,
yeah.
I don't know that word that he's saying
or some immigrant, I'm sure. But yes. But
I don't know if that's a Hungarian word.
A Latin or whatever. They are like, he's
here.
Here's the children.
Hello. So he's being a douchebag.
Samar star. It's like sarcastic
and I don't know if it translates to sons
of a bitches, but Qubein. Yeah, not, yeah.
I mean loosely fuckers go back.
Yeah.
The reading this for them.
For the listeners. What?
Yeah, we should, sorry guys.
I mean, we're just reading it.
Yeah. So there's a Hungarian driver,
I think it's one of those dash cams
and there's these immigrants and he's
screaming like a,
your wives pick up guns and fight isis.
You just fuck around you. Filthy dogs.
Parasite dickheads. Yeah. Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah. I was just like, I'm, I'm
enraptured by this man's level of hate.
You fuck around.
If you felt the dogs,
there's a lot of people walking on
the highway. Yeah. This is usually,
I've only seen in the Middle East.
I've actually never seen this in Hungary,
so it says it's in France. Oh,
trucker Ramsar refugees. Geez.
I didn't know people walk
on the highway in France.
Yeah.
Muscle build up.
He definitely has your fucking
musical tastes too. I liked it.
All this racism is through a dance
like house music due to the dude
your address
fighting against terrorist
with machine guns
rotten,
but I dunno.
It is insane.
Those
plastic craps on the road.
It's not necessary now
because this truck jam is six
diagonal showing up on the IGA
translate. Really what it is is the
immigrants are filthy. They make trash.
They're horrible. They
ruin everything. Yeah.
That's a gay session.
Falash one bossman compulsive hair type
person. There's so many people walking
and they're like,
I think trying to climb on the back.
I think we're trying to hitch rides.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Come down from there.
He is behind me. Oh. So one
of them jumped on his trucks
classic off
the tractor and the trailer.
I liked the beginning. I was
like, I'll go to the highway.
I know what this is terrible.
This poor, these poor people.
Fuck man. Well that's
good to know. You know,
the Hungarians are super sweet and
just really welcoming energy. You know,
kind of have that rep in Europe.
Yeah.
A lot of anti immigrant policies.
They don't like Albanians. They don't
like to guidance. They don't like
Gypsies. They call them
Gypsies. They don't,
they don't like anybody. That's not
Hungarian. Not, I shouldn't say everybody,
but slot. Yeah. Don't, don't
like gays so much either.
It's your tribe.
I know.
Speaking of tribe, I got an
email from a guy about, um,
I fucked up on that crumpets thing.
Um,
this guy's Ronan from Austria and,
and he's right. I fucked it up.
The Guy I was thinking of,
it's named a Sverre to Pete.
Which guy you're talking
about? Um, these European,
why was Santa Claus white is what we're
talking about. And I was like, oh,
maybe because he's a
Nordic st or whatever.
So this guy from Austria
wrote in and said that, no.
So Saint Nicholas is actually from Turkey,
so he may have been darker skin.
Yeah.
And then in the u s I think there were
like caricatures drawn of him in the 18
hundreds that drew him white in the US,
which is probably why we
came to adapt to learn.
My cousin who listened to I think a PBS
thing that the modern day depiction of
Santa Claus as in the fat guy in the
red suit from a Coca Cola ad campaign in
1938 wow.
So before that he had been depicted
as thin and just, you know,
normal like whatever was Saint
Nicholas is thin because I'm hungry.
It's like a modern depiction of the fat
guy in the red suit was in line with a
Coca Cola. Interesting, isn't it?
That advertising how we see it like a
saint by the way, he's the same speed.
The same. Yeah. And so also, so the,
the black guy that I saw in Amsterdam,
right ride toy, that they're like
chocolates of him and everything.
It's not [inaudible], it's the
black guy is called severity Pete.
And it's like Sanchez
homeboy is what that is.
It's like his companion and he's a more
from Spain, which is why he's so Daro.
The more, the more. So there's
that and yeah, I've totally,
I'm sure it's totally racist, right?
It's fucking probably calling now. Um,
okay. So then it's in November six
St Nikolaj comes to your house.
Remember I told you this and you'll
leave your shoes out. This isn't hungry.
It's November six. And if you're good,
you get candy and toys and your shoes.
And if you're bad,
then the devil comes.
And that's named crumpets in
Austria and some other countries,
but I don't know what the fuck they call
it a hungry and they put culinary shoes
and then they hit you with a branches
and sticks because you're a bad kid.
And your parents tell the guy in the
village who dresses up like the devil,
the common hate. You and my uncle got
hit a few years in a row. Yeah. Yeah.
And then on, no, no.
December 24th Christmas Eve.
It's baby baby A's. Wishkah who brings
you toys? Not Santa's. Oh really? Yeah.
So the 24th is our Christmas
and baby Jesus brings you twice.
You hear it's different. Yeah.
I know American holidays.
Most Americans do it where you know
the kid for the whole month is told,
you know, saying it's coming
soon is coming. Yeah. You
know, you meet him at a mall,
he's just on break.
How do you justify the mall?
How do we explain that it's traveling?
Dude is the only,
he's only in town today and then he goes
back to the North Pole and then on the
24th most American kids are
taught that he's out now.
Toliver world to gifts. Yeah. They look
out in the sky. You see up there? Oh yeah.
You see him up there.
He's going to fly all over the world.
So that's why you leave out the cookies
in the milk. You do all that shit.
And then he's supposed to come down the
chimney the night of Christmas Eve so
that when you wake up Christmas Day,
the treats, the treats are there. Yeah,
I know 24th and my house was Christmas,
but he,
my dad didn't tell me
yeas which got brought it.
It's Santa like just came on the 24th.
So we kind of meshed those two holidays.
Yeah. And uh, we go, he'd be like,
let's go for a drive and look for Santa.
And then he'd be like,
I forgot something.
And then he'd run back in and put all
the gifts out and then we come back for a
long drive. You to figure
out like 15, like 16 yeah.
Yeah. How long did you, how
long did you hold out for?
I think by third grade there was a
Jewish kid in our class, Eric Friedman,
and he told all of us, he's like, Whoa,
whoa. I went to a Christian school too.
And he was like, guys, the
Santa thing's not real.
I saw the presence in my parent's
closet and we were like, what? Who Ha?
Who ruined it for you?
Who Ruin it for me. I
think, I don't remember.
I really don't remember how it was ruined.
Um, probably Maria. Probably Maria.
Yeah. Like, oh my God, he's such a kid.
Um, guys, I didn't know
what I do remember.
It was one time Christmas Eve,
she goes,
I saw him standing out the window
and I looked out the window.
I didn't see anything. So I said
that I saw him too when he was like,
I saw my parents were like,
really? And she was like, yeah,
she didn't talk like that that
you did. And I go, I saw him too.
I was so upset that she saw him.
Corey, he's lying. He's a liar.
Liar face.
And now here's what I couldn't imagine
as a kid is being forced to sleep on the
most exciting night. That was a thing
too because the older the kids get,
you know, a young kid you can just,
you know, the kids passed out.
But when you start to get a little older
you can fight those incidents. Yeah.
So did you stay up till like I would
stay up till four in the morning looking
for him. I couldn't, I wouldn't be
able to sleep. Yeah. Did you sleep?
I um, I mean I remember
crashing pretty hard, you know.
I also remember actually when
I finally knew what was up,
having fun playing that game
to my younger sister. Yeah.
Like being in on it because it's fun. It
is fun to do. Yeah. So we, we kept her.
Sure.
We tortured her for a few more years.
How's it can be fine next year when
Elis gets it a little more. Yeah.
This year he doesn't know what's going on.
Yeah. I liked that photo. We got out of,
um, my, my niece, our niece
crying eight months old,
just terrified of Santa Cruz is
like, they always are. At that day.
We didn't take our son to meet Santa
yet cause it was that new fucking Kylie.
Well some stupid store.
It popped up in our neurons are our
mall here and it was just swamped with
people. Yeah. And we couldn't even get
in line for Santos. Too many people.
Way Too many people. Lightweight too much.
Yeah. I don't want to scare my kid. I'll,
I'll wait till next year. Um, this, I
know it was going to make you happy.
So
this is a
from the Netflix.
This is a clip from Netflix.
It's a toilet, toilet
and uh, in an apartment. I mean,
how would you describe the toilet
for our listeners and nightmare?
Somebody made Brown a lot, you know, it's
like the train spotting toilet. Yeah.
It's pretty bad. Look at that whole
area though. I wouldn't shit there.
Even if I had really bad diarrhea.
I don't think I would go there.
Would you hold it? No, I don't like
that. I don't like that shit outside.
If I had diarrhea, I would go out of my
living room before I shit there. Yup. Yup.
One more. One Hand. The
toilet was all plugged.
They said they haven't used it for a year,
so I'm going to take this
up and try to unplug it,
see if there's something stuck
in it or anything. It's called,
here comes your lunch.
And Mikey,
he stuffs it in the time
to get what's going on. How's, what is it?
No. Do. How do you let it get that bad?
Yeah.
Or they said these people said they,
they didn't use the toilet for years.
So why would you,
why would you not?
You know,
how are you just going to neglect
the whole a toilet for a year?
I'd say that's priority in the house
at the toilet's not working. Yeah.
You should probably call. It's kind
of a day one phone call. Right?
Day Two at the latest. I'd
say minute one. Yeah. Hey,
the toilet's broken and all. He's gonna
do his snake, that thing. So what?
You know what I mean? You're paying
to guide is to snake it. Well,
let's see where it goes.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
God bless this man for doing this job.
Or did you call it
or his leg?
What the fuck is in there?
I'll share.
This won't go on the toilet
and the toilet.
We find toys in there sometimes.
Yeah. He's got one lonely
two, one, two feet.
And he just touches that
bare handed the snake.
He picked it up and then he's like,
you did, Bro. How about gloves?
Like, not fucking on
sanitary doesn't give a shit.
Zero shits given him about anything.
You were wearing gloves. I mean,
wearing a hazmat suit
does gnarly is real gnarly
cars to find a lot of those in there.
Or Feminine Hygiene Products.
Oh, that girl, what's up? Rented. When
I pulled the toy, I can fill out. It's,
you suck right there, right? Wash
your fucking hands. Vacuum is start,
smell it again.
This dude knows that the vacuum, he
is going to trigger this smell. Yeah.
So now he's vacuuming up with toilet.
How do you let it get over it? Yeah.
That's so gnarly. Dude. Look at his school
haircut too. What do you call that luck?
That's a pretty much a military
cut. Cop Cut, you know? Yeah.
See Brian's. It's real high and tight.
Yeah, it's a reverse skull. It you like.
I love it. Yeah, Dude, this
guy is disgusting. I mean, I,
I'm sorry I can't get over
just he's covered in feces.
Like it's what he does for work.
He's a busy guy.
Okay. Would you rather 30
seconds. Hold on. Hold on.
Would you rather do this guy's job?
Yeah. Full time is your Gig. Yeah.
Or be a deck hand on below deck out crew.
Outdoor crew.
This guy's job,
we've been watching a lot of below
deck but this uh, the deckhand,
that's it's,
it's 24,
700 of labor. I know. They
clean, it's so hard. Deck.
The windows they get in the water,
the Barnacles,
they scrape it off the hall bitch
work. They do. Then they do,
you know they set up this the toys though.
Inflatable thing.
They fucking carry this lift that
and it's all in out in the sun.
A hundred degree temperature.
But you'd be in such great shape.
Eby you we so rep so fast doing that job.
Damn.
Heat stroke. Definitely. I
can, this is terrible. No,
you would definitely rather be a deck.
I know. I think I would flush toilets
six days to flush the
toilet six days a week.
I can't in look at this from the way and
with Bart, how are you doing? I Dunno.
I mean I'm feel like I'm one of the
thinner guys out there right now. You.
I'm just, I'm not going to,
I know what your number is.
I'm not going to reveal that right
now, but you look amazing. Yup.
You've been a,
you've been very vigilant and I think,
I think the rewards will show, you
have to admit, you have to admit. Yeah.
In the last week,
incredible amounts,
I was shut out of h two o y propaganda.
Why would you look what I'm doing?
I've got a full pint and I've just
finished off a sham meal. Tea.
I'm seriously drinking so much water.
You know why you're bringing it up?
Because it's the first time
you've ever drank that much. No.
And you're so stunned by your brand new
thing. This new thing called hydration.
I get it. You're, it's another level.
I get it. Here's what happened,
and this is also look at the toilet.
I went to her talking spa.
Had a massage. Yeah.
Oh, stop at the story.
God,
why do you drink a lot of water?
I turned and I was like, yeah, it's
pretty well known and she goes,
your muscles feel very hydrated.
I swear on our son's life.
Look in this Iraj well
that's what happened.
I can't roll my eyes far
back enough and my hand goes,
you should just keep that up.
I know.
You know it was a real water champ at
the House that we don't talk about is
bitsy dog drinks. So much
volume of water. Yorkie sips.
She drinks out of her slipper in
the crate and she empties it daily.
I have to refill it and
I'm not exaggerating every
two days. Yeah. Otherwise.
And you know who's not the water champ.
Fif No drinking water.
The other big time water
champ though is our son,
two pounds sippy cups
because he's related to me.
He's just trying to like give it to
them in the morning. He goes boop.
And then when he puts it down,
it's down. I'm like, Holy Shit Man.
My son, he kicks off his day
like that. Just like his dad
[inaudible]
wear a mask,
you know it's going to smell.
That was fantastic.
I think we have to get into the show.
I know you don't call your ta
provider to get the super today.
And I think someone said they
got it on Netflix. Uber off.
You know it's going to stink.
You know it's going to be dirty.
Where I'm asking where your gloves.
Well, we are the shittiest show.
You told me earlier that um, Hitler,
Hitler Guy,
let me a refresh everybody's
memory of what, uh,
an enthusiastic fellow. This
guy is, uh, this guy here
exercise. Okay. In your shoulder
and after you've been mobilized,
it is,
you're going to be just some range of
motion and the range of motion you do.
It's just up to 140 degrees of flection,
which is like how the Hitler.
Hmm. Um, you, you said,
you know who this guy reminds
me of the Evie. Micah.
Just how boring those two
are. God, those two bores.
And if you don't remember
any, my guy, this is him,
33,000 views now.
This was our blood is other views
have like a thousand videos.
Kevin writes, Hey Rick, thanks for the
great programs. I'm really learning a lot.
I'm thinking about buying an Ori
Three 20 for my studio and live shows.
Thanks so much for asking which take
a look at how the capsule is very,
here we go.
Here I have no you already 20 and the
three 20 as you can see they're quite
different.
You already three 20 uses the same
capsule design is in the Ari 27 and d each
had Barry will de fe sports do
you already? 20 zero external
twenties are integrated
into the capital structure.
Theory 20 uses a standard gas
magnet to create a synergy,
uses a neodymium magnet to create a
scope three 20 we'll have a brighter and
higher output.
The Ori 20 sensitivity is 1.5 millivolts
per pascal and the Ori Three 20 says
2.5 mommies and they
both have humbucker coil.
Microphone is best for farts and burps.
The Ori Twenties is an enclosed throw
non binary lines of the abdomen and the
already have about his
variable d explained video.
Yeah, Mike Guy. Thanks for watching.
Reading through our viewer mail and came
across this one. Virginia we can ramp
writes. Hey Rick, I love
you series in my Ed Mike's.
I keep seeing variable d
mentioned in some product specs,
but I'm not really clear on what it is
or what it does. Help me out please down.
Sure. Brent, that's a great question
and thanks so much for asking.
I want to know variable d is an exclusive
ed teacher found on our Ari, Ari,
Ari 27 d and r e three 20 premium mix.
The quick answer is that it's a magical
technology that stabilizes the Mikes
tonal performance throughout an
extended working distance. Yeah,
there's a lot more to it than just that.
Now to know more.
First thing about polar patterns.
Okay.
If the core element of any Mike is fixed
in the front of the element is exposed,
right?
You'll be the direction with the character
sounds arriving from all direction.
Got It. So Mike, yeah, that's
what we want. He's so into this,
which is that exaggerated bass response
you hear when you get right up on the
mic.
Got It.
Had proximity effect in cardio
or just do it in some situations.
Proxy queuing that I've done to these mix
all three of the world show you, um, uh,
they're flat,
there's no additional Sweden.
And then, um, this, uh, so anyways,
that's the evening Micah boring video
in the world. Um, you know what,
this reminds me of marching him.
Hmm.
Being in high school and trying
to take chemistry. Oh yeah.
Well you're just like
chemistry and physics.
I got big solid ds and ds.
I dropped out of chemistry. That's how
stupid. I was like, nope. One of my,
my physics teacher had like chemistry,
chemistry teacher. He liked me so much,
like on a personal level
and he was just like,
basically he talked to me about one
time. He goes like, are you retarded?
Because I, I just, it was like this,
it was like the cardioid actually,
it's a covalent
bond. Oh my God. I'm ready.
Hi Baby.
I love him. Oh my God. This is, um,
lady money made.
This is the Evie Mike Song Guy
made a song
TV. Evie, my guy, Steve. You,
Micah. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi.
Poor guy. I know he's just doing
his thing. He knows someone
march about microphone.
So now this is a cardioid dynamic like,
and I'm going to get
my lip right up on it.
Now I'm directly in front of the mic
with my lip is touching the grill and a,
you hear what it sounds like.
Now I'm going to come out about three
inches on three inches authentic on axis,
three inches off axis. When you go other
side, three inches off actions. No,
that's six inches off
at six inches on axis,
six inches off axis. I'm out to about
10 inches off as I back off of the mic.
Jesus Christ. Do you
think Mike, the Mike Guy,
do you think that sits in a chair with
his legs spread open and boxer shorts and
farts in front of his wife and son?
Maybe into microphones.
We've got to find out which microphone
is the best to pick up farts,
which is the best part. Like,
Hey, this is a call to Rick.
The Mica is the best part.
Mike,
if we wanted to set up a couple of Fart,
Mike's in our studio,
should we get a cardioid mic?
Something with Variable d please,
please let us know.
And very important. Can you make a video?
Can someone email him that question?
So it's in his inbox,
which is the best fart Mike,
he's um, he's a good guy. This guy,
I think he's a nice guy. Oh yeah,
yeah, definitely a good person. Yup.
Probably nice to his wife. Probably does.
What is your thing?
Nice isn't push farts out and
smile at her or stuff like that.
You did give me a lot of head scratches
last night. I'm very thankful for us,
so thank you for that.
We in our household,
I make Tom buy me things for eating
dog food and memory bought me the ring,
but I also,
my other currency is head scratches.
Every time I ask for something you go,
how many head scratches am I going to get?
But you did. You should be more
thankful. All you tell me you go,
I woke up today and there was
a lot of knots in my hair.
Why don't you go like extra tank? You, I
love you. I did. I did. No, you're like,
good job, good job. But you get one a day.
That's how it goes in this house. That
was one good job a day. That's true.
You can't just keep giving him out
and increasing your self esteem. Yeah,
that's true. Good job. Good job.
My Dad and his brother
came over for Christmas on
Christmas Eve and what did you
think? Did you have fun? I enjoyed them
actually. I really had a good time.
I really respect.
I think I told you this,
that what your uncle went to learn a
language and went to learn Spanish and he
went, he did the program where you live
with a family and he's like 70 years old.
How cool is that? Actually, when he was
telling me about it, I was like, man,
I hope when I'm 70 I have that sense
of adventure and you know what the best
part is is that as my uncle was telling
us about his experience in Nicaragua,
my father's eyes couldn't roll far enough
back into his head. It was so funny.
Really funny to him. My Dad's just like,
come on man, this is fucking bullshit.
Your, your, your uncle
was sitting in the kitchen
obstructing the walkway and Jack was get
the fuck out of the way when he shoved
the chair. I know my dad wore
his Christmas track suit.
It was a Ferrari tracksuit and he
made no Kelly for the chicken Paprika.
I should just really nice then to do,
you posted a photo of him
so he only side of his head.
I should post a better one of
him. I will eventually. Uh,
but it's crazy to watch my,
my dad
and my uncle now as, as a four year old
woman with a kid and you're like, oh,
I fucking grew up with that. Like these
guys are, they're just so different world.
Right? Like I feel like they didn't have
it. Another universe. Oh, they're animals.
Three animals are savages. Yeah.
My Dad told me, he goes, Oh yeah,
maneuver a Ellis his age.
I one time I was cutting films together
and you ate a piece of film and I go,
did you call the doctor? He goes,
no, we just waited a little bit.
That's it. Didn't call it
then what? I just shut it out,
I guess you're fine. You're fine. Uh,
swallowed fucking cleaning solution.
Oh yeah. Swag it off. Yeah.
Um, I think the, well my,
the highlight of the dinner was that we
got to talk shit about my ex step mom's
cooking. That was actually really
fun. And you really liked that part?
Yes. Because I, um, here's
the thing. So you know,
when you date somebody from a culture
you hadn't been exposed to before,
you know all your impressions and opinions
about something and become specific
to like what that person teaches
you. Right. When we started dating,
I don't even know if I had met someone
who said they were Hungarian before.
Right. And then, you know,
you introduced me to a Hungarian
traditions and obviously food is like the,
you know, the big part
of a culture. You know,
if you start dating a Dominican person,
they're going to cook specific meals
and be like, this is what we eat.
And same thing goes for anywhere, you
know, German, a Peruvian, anything.
So you, the, the big, you know,
the flagship meal among Hungarians is,
uh,
basically chicken poppy. Gosh,
that's, that's, you know, that's,
that's the signature dish. Yeah.
Yeah. But I was only exposed to your,
it's now I love yours.
I always laugh,
but I'm saying I didn't know
what to expect. Like it,
it's the only thing I have exposure
to. So when you go like, oh, now we,
the first time we went over to your,
your dad's,
when he was with your stepmom and you go,
she's making shipping public hush.
And I was like, Oh shit. Yeah. Because
it, not only did I go do I love this dish.
Yeah. But now I'm, I'm going to eat it
from an off the boat hunger. Right. She's,
she's from the old country.
Yeah.
It's going to be like him over 20 or 30
or something. Right? Yeah. So I was like,
this is going to be off
the charts. Yeah. It was
dog shit, dog sharable. I hated
her food. I hate those hook land.
Terrible. That whole dinner
was terrible. Terrible.
And there's no flavor in any of the stuff.
She had no flavor,
no love in her food,
just like, but the alarming thing to
me was that even that they're split.
See sometimes you know, people divorce.
So they split up and then they go.
And how about the fuckers cooking?
Yeah, I had to live with that.
We're having chicken poppy.
Gosh. And your dad goes,
you know who's a cause you were
talking about your grandmother. Yeah.
When you're like, you made a
good one. Yeah. And he was right.
He was saying he didn't care for it,
which is crazy because my Nana
is, was the vest my, she was an e,
like a terrible human. Yeah. But her
food was really good. Sure. But anyways,
that comes about. He hates his
mother's, you love, you love it.
And then he goes, I'll tell you who's
was good. Yeah. Is x disgusting.
And I couldn't because it was one of the
things that I've held onto for like 10
years was, you know, I
mean, I told you obviously,
but I felt comfortable because they've
been divorced for a while now. I go,
I got to tell you I didn't like that.
And he was like, really? I was like, no,
I didn't like is it feel liberating to
talk shit about the former step parent?
Oh my God.
I hated her food because I was to
the point where it stood out to me.
How bad it can. I tell you other
shit that she messed up like some,
I'm not saying all her stuff
was bad. There's some dishes
she was really good at,
but her stuffing dude,
she used to,
you know like the bag entered
so that they give you,
I know some people put
them in there stuffing,
but hers were like hardened giblets so
it was like you'd be eating like awesome
stuffing and then they'd be like hardened,
I don't know, appendix or whatever.
Acute like a cooking type.
No shame.
Like no loving,
nurturing now. Damn. It
felt good to tell him,
oh my God.
I also wanted to go like,
why are you acting like that was
good because his is terrible too.
So my dad's so chicken public, gosh,
it's just pepper, Paprika, onion, garlic.
It's red chicken dude.
It's not, it's a steal.
It's a stew and all he does
is put the chicken in there,
some garlic and then Paprika.
Right public on there.
And then it's just oil and
then it just looks, it's oily,
greasy cause the chicken juice and
that's it. No, it's disgusting. Yeah.
It's just Greece. Yours is the
dog's minds to vest. You know why?
Cause I got it from uh, this girl
woman named Mcgee. M. E. G. D.
I think she's on the Internet.
And you guys can Google Mug these recipes.
I have a book that she gave me years ago,
but I know she puts out line pasta.
Yeah. Cause the, no, Kelly's
hard to make all my dad did
that. Dumplings. Yeah. Good.
Yeah, I like that too. That's my death
row meal. I could eat that every day.
Oh yeah. And Sour cream. Sour
cream on everything. Fuck man.
She could share. That's one of those
meals to wear. So if you've never had it,
you know, somebody who just is, you're
like, what is all that? What is going on?
It's a lot first bite. It's cause it's
poor people food. It's poor people.
And that's where people, Hungarian stuff
is poor people. Stuff like [inaudible].
It's all,
it's all stu
is the same as me. Like NASA. Mila Nasssa,
right. Which my father loves stammered.
A fried piece of beef. Beaner Schnitzel.
Same thing. All the cultures fry.
I think they fry the, it's the bad
bits so that you can eat the bad bits.
Taller fly. Same with stews. You can
put anything in a stew and you know,
we'll eat it kind of thing.
I'm theorizing, I know
you have these blue jeans.
Uh, can I get, um, uh, number four
as a medium meal with peach sprite.
Ooh. Peach spray a note. That'll be
it. Okay, great. That a medium meal.
Yeah. Right. Thanks. Lot.
That's Anthony Fontez
says here,
how can I help you?
They didn't want me. Can
I get a plane with a,
um, let's see. We'll make
that a large with a, a sprite.
Anything else?
Okay. Was there anything else?
Yeah, I could also get, um,
you guys want to to to uh,
get it to 10 piece chicken mcnuggets I
think he's smiling through it. I love it.
Um, honey, honey mustard. Yeah.
And could also get a large French
fries on the side with that.
And I immediately put shake.
Wow.
It's a lot of food. You know, fucking
Tom died on his birthday. No, Geez.
No Shit. This bride's not quick on the
draw. Yeah, no shit answer already.
Yeah. Oh my God. Yeah. Two
10 pieces. That's correct.
I love nuggets too. All right, thanks.
James
said,
what's your, I don't think there is an
entree. I don't like it. Mcdonald's. Yeah,
Mcdonald's is killer. I maybe I've
never had the chicken sandwich,
but you like that. Well, which
one though? The mic. Chicken.
Well,
when the grilled one and then Halan and
I used to have that when I was actually,
you know, going there, I'm talking like
15 years ago and try and eat healthy.
Get a grilled piece of chicken at you.
Tell them nothing on it, but mustard.
So you know that they're making
it specific to you. Oh, smart.
Or let us know two minute.
And then I would just basically take the
bun off and eat a piece of check. Wow.
But that's a, that's that's a, uh,
a move to make when you have no
options. In other words, you're like,
I'm starving or there's nothing
around here are the to right late.
That's how I would go there. They
have birth and salads now? Yeah,
their fried chicken sandwich. You
don't need the, the one that mattered.
That's what I'm thinking. I'll
eat the fuck out of that. Um,
now the chicken that's on
their chicken sandwiches,
is it the same chicken that's in the
nuggets? Like the poster mash shade.
Chicken nuggets. Oh, all of it. I mean,
one guy that worked at a fast food place
told me never get anything but beef.
Really? He said that beef the, he's like,
if you saw where we're getting half
the stuff, Ronnie goes at least beef,
you know, he, he said it was better to
get beef. Now when are you going to eat?
When you,
hi, what can I get for Ya? Hi Mommy.
I'll do venti iced coffee
with milk and sugar
and a Venti Mocha. Anything
else? Nope, that's it. Eight 51.
Okay. Thanks. Jeans.
CNA. They never say
anything. Never say anything.
It's the perfect crime or like the uh,
the lady earlier. Who are you guys?
Thanks Jeannie. She's like,
you're welcome. Thank yeah.
Well I think number one, the guy was
like, Hey Jean, he heard Jean was my name.
Yeah. Did you kept calling
me jeans? It's hilarious.
So what are you going
to eat after the Diet?
Let's talk about it for people that
don't know, you know, the Bert, um,
burnt Chrysler and I are in a weight loss
contest and it's all about who weighs
less essentially January 2nd and third
is we're going to call it because the way
it first, yeah, the first I fly
back, I mean we could still win,
but it's essentially going to
be about January 2nd and third.
And the reason we're doing back to back
stuff like that is so that like if you
did a big weight cut on the second, you
know, you'd have to continue it for them.
You have to do a two day wait.
Cut. Yes. What you're saying,
you'd have to dehydrate yourself.
So actually like I think on the first
we'll probably call in our ways like, hey,
you know,
maybe stand on the weight on the scale,
take a take a picture and then you know,
we go,
okay, so now, now you know that you
have to do with it for two more days.
You have to weigh in.
Well I was top dog.
I'll take them off.
Hey Buddy.
Hey Dad,
how you doing?
Good. Um, I am in the middle of
something. What are you doing?
45 minute power walk. I mean
Jason, yes, me back in shape. Yeah.
Changed my life. Oh good dad. Good.
Um, I brought my can go ahead.
Did you take a big Christmas
ship by any chance?
No, but I had one today at the
mall and I texted you about it.
Oh that's right.
When did you text me that you uh
oh my like unique in the handicap
stall is like flying first class.
Oh yeah. You have all the room
you want. You got shrunk shank.
Hm. Um, dry are there, you know,
you don't have to worry about being your
elbows tight cause you got room on both
sides. Yeah. You know,
and so I try to use it
is like flying first.
She hasn't like first class,
right?
Yeah. It's like shitting
and yeah. It's nice.
Yeah. And I went in there
and had a real, my real big,
but it's just nice.
Slide four. Okay. Yeah.
Bristol,
Bristol school stool scale for
yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah. It just, you know,
and basically it was,
you know,
I went for whites before
you went three wide.
There was a little bit on the
fourth white. Yeah. And good to go.
It's got to get the toilet.
Yeah.
Yeah. You got to get that washlet you
know what it to clean your asshole.
Yeah. Yeah. But it was a, yeah, I was,
but I tell you that I bought
my calorie look today. Yeah.
It's got calories for every
food and every restaurant item.
That's awesome. Oh Hey, I wanted to
tell you a, I got a joke for you.
What,
what did the policeman say to his stomach?
I don't know.
You're under a vest.
You know what's funny? My Day Joe, just
how horrible it is. Okay. That's fine.
Yeah, I'm on the phone
baby. Okay. All right.
Um, what did I gotta call you
back? Okay. Okay Buddy. Let her,
you have a meeting to go to.
It's yelling your mom.
So he's starting to get fitness too.
Yeah. Well I've been a, I inspired
him. He said when, when I saw him. Um,
so dogs are really going on. What I know
they're playing. What's your first meal?
That's what I'm saying though,
to tell people we're doing this big
weight loss thing and I haven't fucked
around in a while now. Like I haven't
had many cheat meals or snacks.
I mean, yeah. Even when you had
those treats out on Christmas Eve,
but you gotta try, I didn't
even try it. He didn't try it.
So I haven't had sugar starch.
Any like real carbohydrates? No. Yeah, I
get carbs from vegetables, but that's it.
And um, no, I haven't had desserts.
No treats, you know, none.
I tell you, I think the thing,
it's not hard to like, like,
cause once you're focused
on it you're like, yeah,
I'm not having them that in that,
I think what I really want
to have is a waffle waffle.
What do you get on the waffle? I'm
kind of a purist, you know, I like,
I like a Belgian wall. Like
a thicker, yeah, me too. I
like real maple syrup. Yeah.
No, I like aunt Jemima. Fake. I like it
to be, have a little bit of crunch to it.
Yeah. What I mean like, like a little
bit, not burnt, but a little crunch.
Um, and I'll, I'll even
do something where like,
I'll double up or I'll do the syrup and
whipped cream. Oh, I like it like that.
It's like a fucking cake. No fruit, no
chocolate. I mean, I'll do that too.
I'm not a, I'm not the biggest fan
of fruit on, on pancakes and waffles.
Right. You know, some people
would think that's the big treat.
To me it's not that appealing. Well,
because fruit is like, it's good food.
Well it's also, you're,
you're wanting to be bad.
I think it kind of takes away from
the taste that that you're going for.
In other words,
I want the waffle syrup taste.
The fruit then detracts
from it. It doesn't really,
it's not the thrill for me.
Now I know I brought this up to you
probably a million times in the last 10
years, but we got to go to Belgium.
Belgium. Yeah. That's spelled the M. Yup.
Uh, to get a Belgian waffle. You've
told me this. Yeah. Yeah. You will.
I kind of want to fly there just for
this and do it because you will shut your
pants. How much better those waffles are
than the American shit you have here.
Yeah. Cause there though, their
waffles are like really thick,
crunchy and you get them on the street
and the streets just smell that wonderful
waffle
smell. No. Oh my God. Go to remind
some other people. Let's see.
MMM.
What's going on? The stakes
of the, of the bed. Okay.
If I lose,
I have to take Bertrand to the
Superbowl in Houston on February 5th.
Oh, that's coming up. Yeah. So I
have to buy tickets. Air Superbowl.
It's expensive. Yeah, it's
very expensive to go to. Um,
so that'd be February 5th. And I also,
if I lose, I have to shave my beard,
which is such a hassle to hassle.
I mean, I like having a beard,
but he just had Allen trim it up.
It's going to be so annoying.
It's going to suck if he loses.
I chose,
I want it because it was
about go to a sporting event.
I've never seen Barcelona play
soccer and they're like, you know,
they're like the 96 Chicago Bulls.
They are superstars.
I decided I want to go see Barcelona
play Paris, um, in this like,
I think it's the one of the cup
finals or some stage of it. Um,
February 14th, Valentine's Day,
which we don't give a fuck about,
so I'm fine with that.
Thanks jeans. But, um,
that means he has to take me to Paris.
Great.
And buy tickets to the game flight.
And so to me,
if he loses his shave his beard too.
Oh my God.
So we're going to see just how fat his
face. Yeah. How long has he had that?
He's always had a beard. No, he
had a goatee for a long time. Oh,
remember you don't remember?
Yeah, I do. I do. I do remember.
Oh Wow. That's exciting genes.
So you love a football? Yeah.
How exciting. That'll be fun. They
go nuts for soccer over there, man.
Oh right. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
sure, sure. I'm like wait,
did his first special. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
Ooh.
Yeah. And then there isn't it. Yeah.
I like his beard veteran at the beer
is better than the goatee. Yeah.
They go to you, like you said, just looks
like heroin around an asshole. Yeah.
It makes your lips look
like an asshole. Yeah. Yeah.
Plus it cuts in the
most unflattering place.
See how has Chan is not,
yeah,
it creates a double Chin or accentuates
kind of created the double chin,
but yeah, I know what you're saying.
I'm trying to be, you know, kind. Yeah.
Well, well Burt, um, wow.
You mean you're going to
take him to Paris Shit. Yeah.
I'm tagging me to Paris as well.
We're going to hear a lot of,
I know I can't and we should get
Leanne involved in this more.
I need to hear her. Her side. Yeah.
You should try calling your call. Yeah.
Let's see. Let's see how he's doing.
Let's, let's talk to Leanne. Okay.
Set this up real quick. I have
her number. Do you have it?
I might actually have it,
but just give me one second.
Um,
hoof.
I don't think it's even on this phone.
On this computer. Let's see.
Oh, it's on the other computer.
I have it right here. What do
you see? What? Just using this,
Oh,
here I have her number of uni.
I'll send it to share contact.
Um, Miss Lean crash.
You may use my name. Uh,
what's Burt doing right now is
I'm showering in the backyard.
My Pay Shit. He does, right? He does. He,
he hoses himself down in the
backyard after a workout. Oh,
so while you're doing that,
I would like to update the
listeners on a little English thing,
the Internet stuff.
There was a clear last week and I was
perplexed by the [inaudible] in it and
that thing because it didn't make logical
sense that they would say, isn't it?
And I got a tweet from
someone from Raz. Oh, Raz,
Ra's Rac. Uh, hey gene, just
to fill you in. I like that.
I'm gene now just to fill you in,
in it as both a short form of isn't it?
And an alternative. No, I'm saying Gotcha.
So that would make sense in a, in a,
you know what I'm saying? You
know what I'm saying? Yeah. Okay.
Very cool in it.
And a m that amen and amen.
Okay.
Let's see if we can get a
and to comment on Bertrand's eating.
Oh,
here we go.
Okay. I hope she likes me
too. She's probably good.
Yeah.
Okay.
She might pick up for you. She loves
me. This is coming from a Skype.
Oh.
Should I text her?
No.
Shit.
She's not gonna she's not gonna Answer.
Yeah.
Your call has been forwarded to an
automatic voice message. Says, oh wow.
Do you think we can, uh,
hold on from Skype. Hey,
Tom and I are calling you from Skype.
She's not Leanne so busy.
She's not the type to have her phone
on her all the time. Yeah. She's like,
I'm real mom. Well let me know if she,
if she writes back here and minute,
well yeah,
two children,
one phone around if a child,
if she had one morbidly obese adult
child, if she, if she will actually,
um, you know. Okay. In the meantime,
I also had an epiphany,
like a big one,
like you remember for the longest
time I didn't know that. Fage younger.
Yeah,
that's good one.
And then five that you can tilt the sweet
part over and put that the fruity bart
on your yoga.
I didn't know that for the longest time
I was scooping out and then putting it
on the yogurt, the Greek yogurt. Yeah.
Then smart and final happened
member where I go, I,
I thought it was like an office store
when it was late. Yeah, you're smart.
But all sales are final. And then
we looked up what it was, wait.
And I had no idea of smart and final is
like a grocery store still doesn't seem
like a good name.
You thought it was corporate,
a corporate board set of a
store that was like, yeah,
you're smart for shopping here,
but all sales are final.
I thought it was like a final sales place.
It was like essentially consulting their
customers. Right? It's smart and final.
No,
like it's you're smart to shop here,
but all sales are final because this
is like a close out discount store.
That's what I thought.
Smart and final one is your last chance
to get this item and then El Torito.
Yeah,
we were El to,
we're not what and where they were in
the parking lot and I see El Torito and
then I see the little symbol of
a bull and I put it together.
El Torito is the little bowl.
Toto is,
yeah. Now did you know that or I never
thought of it. I really didn't. I really,
three years I was like, Oh el Torito l
three I thought it meant like El Tortilla.
I thought of a Tortilla for some
reason. Not a tiny bowl. Right.
I mean, sorry. It's a big deal
for me. I guess you are not blown.
Are Real excited about it.
I do remember that you thought it was
like some significant breakthrough,
but you don't think that's crazy that
for 40 years of my adult life I el Torito
just didn't make sense to me really.
It was like a Mexican name. Right.
And now I get it. I fucking get it.
No, now you get it. No, I get it.
That that's pretty cool.
And actually it was my mind open
for someone that speaks, you know,
pretty good Spanish. I never thought
of El Torito being the little, little,
little thing. Just like your
roots Chris's. I get bothered.
You like this is kind of on par
with Chris Ruth's. Chris is Chris.
Chris.
It's Chris Steakhouse and Ruth bought it.
It's a Ruth's Chris Steak House.
Yeah.
Yeah. Our third son, Carl's Jr.
No, Tom's Ruth's Chris. Tom.
We're not going to name our next son tells
Ruth's Chris third son will be having
a third song.
Chris,
I can will be Carl's Jr Ellis is going
to feel super left out cause he's not
food themed. Yeah, we'll just be like,
well you know you should have been born
later. No. Can we call him a in and out?
You want to just call him that?
It's a double entendre.
That's how he was conceived.
And I ate an in and out twice a
week when I was pregnant with you.
Love some in and out.
God Damn. Yeah. Well,
do you love it more than your Western
Bacon Barbecue? I do because it's fresher.
What? Carl's Jr Western Bacon there.
The meats frozen. It's no good.
But I do love the onion rings and the
barbecue sauce, the cheese and the bacon.
God Damn, man. I got to talk in a couple
of funny things to play for you. Oh yeah,
thanks Jean.
And money.
This guy gets convicted of a crime and
then he sings and apology and court shit.
I'm sure he's totally
sane, right? Oh Shit.
It looks good.
I'm fucking up already.
Forgot to switch the audio back. Oh
No, it's okay. No, I mean, oh no,
this guy, he's probably not pleasing
the judge. Isn't that a good,
um,
can you reveal Facebook?
Yeah, dude, he uh,
uh, no. I want to see how I'm sorry,
father
things
you're not,
try and be stronger.
Okay.
And this life shows,
but I want you to know
no,
that close.
Do you think his, his, uh, his
attorney is cringing or just a, well,
I'm trying to figure out
what Satan's doing here and
the suit. Yeah, that's fine.
Can your honor, I'm sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Voice, right? Yeah, he does
to my mother.
I'm sorry.
My son.
It's a nice song.
Tell him I'm sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry. Yes, your honor. I'm sorry.
You saw,
you saw you saw him.
Uh, thank you, your honor.
That's so weird. It's weird, but it was,
it was kind of heartfelt now. I mean,
it was heartfelt, but I don't know
if the, if he said to the victim,
I don't know if they want to hear a song.
Yeah. It's kind of a weird Kelly. Yeah.
Speaking of choral singing, George
Michael Died. I know. I hate it.
And they gave you that weird thing of
like, oh, his, he had heart failure,
which just means he, he took too many
pills before. Usually it's all guys. Yeah,
no guys. Yeah, we can't, by the way,
just for people that are under
basically younger than me. Um,
if you didn't, if you know,
if you're younger than 35,
you probably have no recollection
of how massive this dude.
Wow. I mean, I Miss Sarah was a
stretch where he dominated MTV.
It was just oh, phases. But I mean,
it wasn't, I was looking today I go,
I want to look at some of these, you
know, George Michael's songs freedom. Ah,
it's a good one. Yeah.
Faith. I want your sex.
I mean those like those songs right there,
each were number one hits.
Don't forget careless whisker.
Ah, well here's the thing.
We can't play them because youtube
will take you down for copyright.
But I was thinking was I could throw
in an earpiece just for some people and
give you, you know what I mean? Some
flavor of it. Well, I mean, I can,
I can make it so in case
you're not familiar, what
song did you want to saying?
Well, what do you want to
hear? That's fairly careless
whiskers. Okay, let me see.
Um, I'll pull up the lyrics.
Careless whisper lyrics.
Here we go. And okay. I put this earpiece
in such a heartfelt memory.
He was so serious. He's never
gonna dance again. Yeah,
it's really good. Guilty
fee. See who. Okay.
And you have such a good voice. Can I
sing it? Just music, man, man, man, man.
Right now it's just a keyboard.
Oh, I'm trying to pay tribute.
So if you don't mind
having a little respect,
go ahead and just have a little respect.
I'm trying.
It's still music and it's
just kind of building.
Ah,
so ah,
show is that, it is a really
long buildup for this to start.
We'll sing it right. 32nd
them. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Uh,
uh,
uh Huh.
To the right. Mm hmm.
There's no comfort in the truth,
Huh?
Okay. Pick a song. You know the words
to, I had the lyrics in front of me.
That was really good to know.
Okay.
Do you like it or no? Nope. Okay.
Which one would you like to hear?
Shane Lee does a better job than
you. That's really insulting. Well,
he's the master if you want. I want
your sex, faith, freedom to faith.
That's a hard one. Okay. It's
fast. It's really fast. Okay,
well I guess it would be
nice, right? Yeah. Let's see.
Know you don't know the
words to fucking faith. Well,
I'm trying to do you a child
of the eighties or not and
Wham is good. Remember?
Yeah, of course. Did or
bug. Okay. Just went boom.
And then my farts. Boop, boop. We're
trying to pay tribute if you don't mind.
God gave her farts into my file here.
We good.
God. Little Oregon, little church Oregon
playing right at the beginning of faith.
Everybody knows that.
No,
we're doing this for the people that
don't know that experience right now.
They're going to get the George
Michael Experience through me.
A guitar and yet the
Acoustic Guitar. No, Oregon.
Tom, give us the experience.
I'm about to. Okay, here we go.
Ready? Here we go. Shh.
Quiet dance, dance, dance,
dance, dance, dance, Duh.
Cause it would be nice
if I could touch it.
I know not everybody has got
a bad luck. You, there you go.
That was nice. We'll
sing the rest twice, kid.
Mahana ah,
the Games you because I play,
but uh, you need some time, Huh?
Stop looking at me like that.
Horrible. You're terrible
Stan.
Thank you Tom. That was
wonderful. Thank you. I'm
showing you the door at the floor.
Okay.
And thank you for the retarded version.
By the way. You remember a time,
I didn't know he was gay when I was right.
I was going to say,
so wham was a band he came
out with like come out,
but he was in a band called wham.
That was like, that was colossal.
So the song is wake me up before you go.
Go.
It's a really catchy and in
the video. Yeah, go ahead.
Write me up before you
go. Go. There you go.
I'm not planning on go and
so low. Okay. Right. Yeah,
yeah, that's it. That's it.
So it was him and his band mates and
they were wearing the shortest of shorts
and there was a catwalk on a stage and
they were wearing shorts that said choose
life.
And they were like clapping and they're
short sleeves were rolled up and the
short shorts and they're clapping. And
it was the 80 so people were in the boy.
George was popular too. And everybody's
like, are they gay? Is that gay? They,
we don't know. We don't know. And
then surprise, he's totally game.
Well, even at the height of this
stuff, like I want your sex faith.
That's when he was a member of the
tight jeans and the left. Yeah. Yeah.
And he had the real,
the [inaudible].
And I still remember women would lose
their mind. I had a crush on him.
My sister and Maria and her friends
thought saw Ha's Sysa sets up by a lot.
He was super high. And I was like, oh,
that's what like, because in my mind,
you know,
at that age,
my only idea of gay had to
be a super feminine like
that. So I couldn't comprehend.
Yeah, I think most of us,
not that I couldn't comprehend, it didn't
occur to me. I was like, Oh that guy.
But I think that's why we were so like
a merit. We were so under there, we,
he was so under the radar with us because
we thought of gay dudes like Liberace
was gay, exact, not George because George
Michael, the women loved him. They loved,
we all loved him. And so, and then his
HBO had all the naked models. Oh my God,
that was the best one. They
all said later like, Oh yeah,
of course we all knew him.
We all knew. You know,
it's so funny cause back then
being gay was such a big deal.
Even when Liberace died,
he died of AIDS and right.
The couldn't even really say it. They
didn't want to say it. So sad by the way.
And I mean this sincerely. Rest in
peace, George. My ground. It's very,
it's very sad. He's 53
years old. So young. God,
that's just fucking suck.
We don't have many of our legends left.
I think we have Madonna.
Yeah, we have, uh,
is is uh, Boy George still alive?
He is right. Yeah. As far as I know.
Um,
so this is apparently the United way.
Do you remember Frankie goes to
Hollywood, relax, don't do it.
We didn't know he was gay
either. Yeah. You want to come.
He got away with saying
that and it is Lou. Yeah.
What you don't want to come because it
used to be every fucking dad would play
that. Yeah. In the car. I'd be like,
well my dad and I let know Bob is Bob
his head and then all of a sudden someone
just tells you, Oh, do you know
what this song's about? I Dunno.
It was just real quick cause it's so good.
That's the thing about catchy. Catchy.
We'll lose you.
Yeah.
He made a hit song about busing
nuts not busting that right? Yeah.
I mean I bet most so Chris, you
know, Middle America was like,
oh it was such a cadre. So relax, don't
do it. It was a great song. And you get,
wait when you want to
stock to it or whatever.
Why do you want to come?
And he's all,
and at the end he's all ah
Hah, I need you Shira. Him,
he fucking big ox at the end of the
time. Sure. That was a little girl.
Leah loved the song, the song. So
those dudes were totally gay too. Yeah.
There were just like the case
and are like,
would you ever want to marry your mom?
So I was like,
really good county.
When did you marry your dad?
Oh, never easy. Um, it's something that,
you know, as a team you just gotta Kinda,
you know, I guess you want to
take a breath and uh, you know,
refocus and, you know, look
back to what made us, you know,
when those games
we're just going through, your nose is
glass and he had some dip in his lip.
He sure did. I used to ride her dip like
that. Can't see you doing that. Yeah,
I did. I don't like that. Really.
Yeah. Stay on the same level and,
you know, get back to, you know,
the simple things that,
you know, made us win.
Okay.
Well I guess I haven't really paid
attention, I guess enough. But you know,
you always say like, you know, it's
a score on the road and, you know,
keep it simple and, you know, we should
be doing that at home too. It's, uh,
you know,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think it's just, you know, just for the
whole team, it's just, you know, another,
another guy that you know, brings,
you know, leadership and you know,
everything that she feels, you
know, on the ice. He's a, you know,
one of the hardest working guys. You
know, a good center man. For us that's a,
it means a lot. And just, you
know, in every aspect of the room.
Yeah. So what's this
professional microphone? Oh,
a lot of journalists do that just drive.
Yeah.
Well they're not playing on the air it
so that they can right there. Oh, oh, oh,
I'm there Brad. And you always made
the very important distinction many,
many years ago. Thank
you. That, uh, you know,
and you know what I'm saying are
very different. Totally different.
You would agree that as far as you knows,
this guy's killing it, killing, you know,
game. I haven't counted them,
but it's a lot. Let's see if we,
no, you know, you know, you
know, you know, you know, like,
you know, New York, you know,
you know, you know, you know, you don't,
you don't see, you know, you know,
you know, you know, you
know, and just, you know,
I would say it's about 20. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a lot of, you know,
Sandy Canadian submission gets
extra points. Dustin, what is it by,
by Fugley I said his name. I don't
know. I played for the jets. Winnipeg,
the great city of Winnipeg. Um, yeah,
we don't get a lot of canal. This might
be the first, you know, but you know,
uh, as far as you know, counters go, I
feel like this guy is near the top. Yeah,
yeah. He's in the, in the, you know, game.
He's at the top of his game, you know.
I know, I know, I know.
Then there's that one that was the
only, cause, you know, you know,
you know,
you know, it doesn't look very nice.
Um, yeah, I know what you're saying.
You know what I'm saying? I know what
you're saying. You feel me? Don't,
I'm talking about,
you know what I'm saying,
that who was the guy that did the triple,
you know what I'm saying? If you don't,
you're only talking about
the trip was saying that.
Yeah, I bounce. That was good. I'll see if
I can find him. You know what I'm saying?
You feel me? What I'm talking about.
You know what I'm saying? I'm feeling,
I'm talking about best one. Let's see. Ha.
And the shuck night via
sleep top interview.
I feel like this is it right here.
Oh for fuck your mother.
Um,
here we go. You know, you go.
No, but I was telling my
music mode today to me on me,
I was writing music gave me day.
You hear me? I'm all about 15
every day.
You know what I mean? Family. Yeah, yeah.
I mean filming that was a good one. Yeah.
You don't have to get the
to conjoin. Like, you know,
I got an a, so when I started my
on exhibit exhibit out when he had,
I mean, it just lick now, man.
It's gone. One study, I mean,
crying, not for the agony.
Did my Niggas, I'm inside the crime
now for the agony I'm talking about.
And then my Nigga, you feel me?
I mean, so they already had,
and Mitch just leaving me. I
mean, they already had, I mean,
they already had their little group. Yeah,
Bang. I fell in. But they grow. Yeah.
I like, ma'am, ma'am,
I realize that. Wow. I've pulled that
from memory. That was really amazing.
This is like a live clip that you found?
Yeah,
my ex. Even me. I mean, so, and
then after that it's, I mean,
I'll start fucking with me.
It's like really
right now by that he's going back
and forth. He's doing feel me.
You know what I mean? Sometimes just not,
I mean, but then he does. You feel me.
I'm talking about, you know what I mean?
Which is the TRIFECTA. Right? So in a way,
on my phone, you know what I mean? In
a way, this is one of the most complex,
you know what I'm saying? Oh,
we've ever had, without a doubt,
this is the most complex. Yeah.
Not One of, it's a layered.
It's multifaceted. When he does the
triple, you know what I mean? Yeah,
that absolutely blew my mind.
Right. We made a shirt about it.
There was a time about your
film, you know, I mean sure, yes.
Knew new firm and it just
became also going to learn.
I'm mom con [inaudible] so there is snap
app camp and I didn't get to see it.
Did you get any
sort of a backlash look the man Diego do
as opposed to somebody else in Calais.
And how does that work out?
No, not really. Not, not
even. Not when y'all get no,
no negative nothing.
I mean cause my Nigga Nigga,
Nigga some Nigga. Yeah man. So yeah man,
he just collaborated with a real Nigga
for me, the war, that's all it was.
He was saying he was just
doing now means for a second
came with about Nigga,
you guys sit out was made worldwide one
kind of angles on and that was just like
you from me. I mean that's
all it was. I mean, but yeah.
Nah Man,
you know they feel but ain't no it ain't.
No I'm talking about is
still in the bag right there.
Nobody talking bad about each [inaudible]
I mean they know go fuck a world.
Boom. Real fucked up. The real, yeah.
I mean that's all I knew was oh yeah,
I got that new exclusive y'all mean was
way babby I'm not just putting it out
something I just really like really cut
it out. So I mean got a really light.
Yeah. I mean cause now that
exclusive feature and Jessica Rabbit,
you know she from the bay, I mean
she fucking mess in Waianae the yeah,
you can go get that on.
I told Amazon wrapped by Sydney,
Google play eggs buyers live.
There you go. Oh yeah, boy
shit. My nigga snake. Yeah,
me and put me,
obey me up like me and we got this new
track won't stop beating blood like
interns down to the real dummies.
Some real niggas [inaudible]
around town like like Yay.
I know would,
hi Ruth filing.
I'm talking about know to be in Brown
Khan records and it your time off steady
gang. I'm talking about and
yet act, clack, clack, clack,
clack, clack, clack, clack,
clack, clack, clack clack.
There you go. Do my mind is blown
out. It was wild. This is a,
maybe.
Maybe this is the quick
you an angle you, anyone can find
you now tell him a young man,
your rice porridge quiet
man to go and here is,
I was a baby. I mean it was, I mean,
you know it was hard to me young guy
you're doing this day. I mean they not me.
I was about that and I mean real
Nigga I ain't writing bang on.
I mean so no Nigga had a lot of
privates 72 times in the that,
I mean,
yeah,
prior [inaudible] got a lot of problems
with the law and needing many jail
newsman at juvenile hall and camp.
Why Jesus in a penitentiary.
The county did a nude and did all that
and so I'm talking about you telling me,
I mean,
but now
I know money.
Yeah, we can't play that. No, no,
my uncle. But that's the number. A
lot of thought and five one guy, man,
I hadn't been now for a couple
more things. I mean, I didn't,
I've never been there for a
while. A gang says, I mean,
but I ain't even gonna speak on this.
I ain't gone anyone to
speak on all of that. Right.
You mean I beat that shoving 12 in the
box and meet that. So I'm talking about
in my music name, banging on wax. I mean
definitely it's special.
It's like a double rainbow
all the way. Triple Rainbow,
chivalry,
triple
bang. Niggas know I bang, but
I'm not making them my music.
I keep it 1000 I don't beat around
the bush. I don't know. No sugar.
I mean, so, but I'm not
banging. I'm not dissing nobody.
I fucking cribs. I fuck bloods.
I fuck with Eric [inaudible],
gangster disciple stuff like whatever.
But I love and who else?
I have no idea as God blesses.
Oh that's, that's him.
God blesses it.
Yeah.
I love people. I love what I'm about. So
I may as long time for me. I'm a load.
You fuck with the mom con I love you.
You let the wrong card. I love you.
That's how I did. He said me got me. I
collaborate with anybody, any crib, Nigga.
But like,
I mean like,
thank you.
I feel like I've got it.
Stupid young talks about being fresh
out of prison and getting back on track.
Stupid Young. That's
his name. His rap name.
I don't know if I'd call myself stupid.
I'm super young man. Yeah. Stupid Young.
Yeah, I know about that one guy
that made me laugh really hard.
I got it. I think I understand.
Yeah. It's just, listen,
I don't know if I can listen to him.
He'll, we've been with this
Spanish, but me personally, I mean,
I fucks with essays all day. You feel me?
I'm not supposed to be meeting my Nigga.
I don't understand what is happening
here. Yeah, that was a lot.
He fucks with the essays. He's talking
about you saying Latinos. Latinos. Yeah.
He does his thing. You know what I'm
saying? You don't, I'm talking about,
you know, uh, no,
I haven't really done vocal fry stuff.
His name is plies and half ounce,
right? Like, no, it's totally
different person. Why why'd
you talking about applies?
I thought his name was plotting.
He's, he shouted out supplies diddy.
I thought I heard him. I thought he said
shout out to [inaudible]. Oh, sorry.
So his name is half ounce.
Half ounce. Yeah. Okay.
I didn't know it was Aka was
plies. No, no, no, no, no.
A totally different like the philosopher
who gives the wisdom. Oh yeah, okay.
That's a nice way of putting
it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sorry,
you were saying vocal fry. Oh
yeah, yeah. I love it. I love it.
We haven't tapped on it a long time. I
don't have my fucking board set up, but
apparently there's a really
crazy vocal fry in a commercial.
It's everywhere.
I'm Maureen Petrosky entertaining expert.
Wow.
It's terrible.
She is a entertaining expert,
entertaining expert. Listen to that. You
guys know what we're looking for, right?
Vocal fry is when you do that,
it's actually forced you,
you don't do it naturally,
but some people get so
accustomed to talking like
that, that they, um, you know,
they talk like it all the time and it's
prevalent amongst younger women to sound
smarter.
Like some of the Kardashians.
I'm Maureen Petrosky,
I'm entertaining, expert
bearable. It's insecure sounding cause
you're not projecting. And she goes,
she also did that,
that
Bob's are perfect for cooking outdoors
over the grill or an open fire.
How I is extended by fire.
She said fire.
Yeah.
And it's up talk at the end if
there's fire or an open fire
cooking outdoors grill or an open fire.
One way to combine dessert and cocktails
is to add a shot of whiskey to your hot
cocoa and hot cargo God
or vocal fry is terrible
shot of whisky cookout.
You sound really dumb when you talk
about toasted marshmallows and Graham
cracker crumbs thing to a night
around a fire line and grom caulker
grom monchago crime.
And you have a sweet ending to a night
around the Graham cracker crumbs and you
have a sweet tooth at night around a fire.
Uh,
hi. So prevalent. It's really,
you know what you've been
making me laugh by hi. Yeah.
Around the house so much is when you're,
when you curse at Bitsy,
cause you really get mad at her.
You're like Bitsy,
you asshole.
Well, if she's, look, she's adorable.
She's the sweetest dog. Fuck off,
but he's so dumb.
She's the dumbest dog I've
ever been around and literally
I'm holding our son or
I'm carrying a box and I dunno.
Most every dog I've ever
had or been around like sees
you. And they go like, oh,
I'll go here.
She does the exact opposite.
She sees you and then steps in front
of you in front of your feet. Slip on
her. I step on her. I'm always
like, what the fuck are you
doing? And she's like, ah,
it's unnerving. And whenever the
kid drops any morsel of food,
anything Fitzy chews it up.
Immediate doesn't choose feathers,
plastic rocks, glass Christmas tree
tree, and she barfed it right up.
I'm sure that's not good
for dogs on real late plan.
Okay,
you're more for Kit Kat.
Can I hear it again though?
I'm entertaining expert.
Oh my God.
These are perfect for cooking outdoors
over the griller and open fire.
A fun way to combine dessert and cocktails
is to add a shot of whiskey to your
hot cookout.
Top it off with some toasted marshmallows
and Graham cracker crumbs and you have
a sweet ending to a night or on fire
of how many calories is. I would think
that a director would just be like,
you need to stop talking like that
when we were going to shoot this
whole thing again, stop going by air.
Sound like an idiot. Yeah, you did
a really nice treat for your open
fire would be to talk like a person.
Just project. Cause what you're, you're,
you're like intentional and kind of going
down. You're right. It's intentional.
It's lazy speed. Cause you're like,
uh, it's like you just woke up.
I'm just getting up man.
So Lazy.
So Lazy. Stop talking like
that. You asshole. Oh there's
more, there is more. Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah. Don't have to stress
out with last minute guest.
Just look and see what you have and work.
No Shit.
And the device
for me,
I'm serving a Jack Daniel's single barrel.
Select the barrel proof and also the Rye.
So there's something for every taste.
The batter,
the ride. You do hear that. The Barrow,
it was ridiculous. She's a bad though.
You know what, I think it might be
okay, here's a theory because she
appetizers can be as easy as assembling
some things from your pantry.
It looks fancy but it's so easy
cause she's,
she's actually talking really soft.
Maybe cause that's an ADR. Meaning
she had to go and record a voiceover.
Maybe she's not used to being on a
microphone and hearing yours cause it is
louder than normal. So maybe it's
just like being Tim and work with it.
Oh our
pantry
pantry.
That's bad.
The really strong,
the barrows way play the beginning of it.
She got the Barrow and the Ry.
You don't have to stress out with last
minute guest just and look and see what
you have and work with it.
Oh stupid advice.
No Shit.
I'm serving a Jack Daniel's single barrel.
Select the barrel proof and also the Rye.
So there's something high taste
a horrible.
So we got oh funny
youtube comment ready I,
one of our videos about Steven
Seagal. Oh yeah. So they sent us this.
Who are these about us? Who are
these two ass clowns? Exactly.
They are playing the video of an
interview conducted by someone else and
interview, neither of them could
ever hope to conduct themselves,
even if they somehow did both would
sit there silent as the grave,
as Steven Seagal towered over them,
reverberating the same answer as
he did the real interviewer. Why?
Because he is Steven Seagal and they
are a couple of nobodies who hosted a no
name talentless radio show that features
talking about other people who have
accomplished, seen and done more
than they could ever hope to do.
The entire premise of this
video is ridiculous and I'm
annoyed for even clicking
on it.
Oh,
Steven Seagal could or could not
be the biggest joke on the planet,
but no matter what plant he is on,
these two are far below him.
It's not even funny. Try
getting a real show Bozos. Wow.
So he's not even really at the end.
It sounds like he's not defending weird,
but just that we are below Stevens ago,
so he needs to let us know.
Thank you sir for letting us know
and if I have any unexpected gas,
uh,
the Ra in there.
Um, and then the, another comment was
this is about you that big. It's like,
I need to hear that that bitch was to
throw up because the Stevens to Gaul.
I want to throw up at that grime inside
her Coffee Cup. It's a good point.
There you go, dad. Bitch. Yeah.
Do you talked about uh, Oh, you
talked about Black Santa, right?
Yeah, that's why I know. Oh,
so you're ready. Read that.
Okay. Okay. Um, would you,
do you want to do the, would you
rather they sent, I haven't read that.
I don't approve of it if I haven't
read it. Oh, okay. I won't improve.
Chris genes is a racist. Yup. Here we go.
She said cowboys not diarrhea is the
most racist thing mommy see us ever said
when talking about Indians cowboy.
Oh, right. No, no, that's wrong.
I said diarrhea, not cowboy. Right.
So if you're going to quote the joke,
at least get it correct. That's not what
I said, right. You were saying, yeah,
it's uh, go ahead and so
wait, where am I racist?
Because that was the way you specify
to which India and you were talking.
Oh, okay. Thank you for
pointing that out. Yeah.
Maybe I could drank over I
in
the pantry
pantry. Um, so what,
we've got to wrap this up. What
is your thought on the skull? It,
we didn't do our dates. Oh, okay.
Well Shit. Fucking do them now.
[inaudible] and first and
foremost, February 12th,
we're doing your mom's house.
Live
at the Irvine improve.
Come and see us to the show
live. We sold them. Do it. So,
um,
come and see it as a big show.
And then May 4th and fifth, I'm in
Fart. Next Arizona at stand up live.
May 19th to 20th,
New York City at Gotham comedy club.
June 16th and 17th, and man,
friend disco at the punchline.
So come see me do those dates guys. Secura
what do you got? A, I'm in horror. Lando,
Florida for New Year's Eve.
Um,
then cans ass shitty for a,
the first week of January.
Then I'm in Oxnard,
Cox hard at,
uh, and then when the big, the
big leg of my tour begins, uh,
go to Tom segura.com/tour and,
um,
some shows have sold out
and we're not adding even.
So make sure you get your tickets. Now.
Like for instance, Atlanta's sold out.
We're not doing a second show.
Uh,
there's still some tickets
left for new or jeans,
Louisiana clear. Farter
your Tampon, Florida,
Tallahassee. So, um, get your tickets.
A bunch of those are going to sell out.
We've added a third show in
Boston at the Wilbur. Um,
there's a third show in mommy,
apple, tits, Minneapolis. And um,
there's a third. Is there a third?
CHICAGO? No, there's a second. Chicago.
There's a second royal oak.
There's a second. Portland, Oregon.
The first one sold out
and that's an April.
So you've got to hop on those
tickets. Just check out the
page. Tom, cigarette out,
Donald Blah Blah. Thompson, grow.com/tour.
Um,
that's said jeans.
[inaudible] go. [inaudible]
Oh, I didn't address this.
I want to address this. Uh, this is
heartfelt. This really bothered me.
The first round of glass
and shirts that went out,
I thought you were saying we're
in Israel. I was like, I said,
you're gonna tell me something. Put
me on blast. No, call me a racist.
Like that other person just did the first
round of glass and shirts were below
our standard.
And it upset me greatly because we've
worked really hard to establish a,
um, you know, uh, a consistency where,
you know, when you get a shirt from us,
that is a certain level.
And so now do I want to apologize.
The people who got, everybody
that has ordered one now,
it's already been changed.
It's been upgraded to a better shirt.
We started working with a new company.
They've done a fantastic job.
So I'm not throwing them under the bus.
There was just a miscommunication when
we placed this order because basically
what happens is you get a design,
you, you know, you email. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Order this quantity.
Do this, do that.
The previous of shirts had sold out.
They sent me a thing.
Do you want the same price for this?
And in that we lost that it
would be a quality difference.
So it's super bummed me out.
Um,
I want to make it up to people that got
the lower quality shirt and I've been
trying to figure out a way to do it.
One thing that I thought of
was if you send an email,
um, and maybe I'll set up a new
email address for it, you know,
so it's just for that,
I'll do that.
I'll set up a new email address for the
next episode and I'll tell you what it
is. And if you have one of
those first glass and shirts,
that's a Gildan shirt, um, you're
going to send an email to this address.
It'll just confirm that,
that you were,
you ordered one and it was sent to you
and then I'm going to send you a small
makeup, a Freebie. Nice. Very good.
That's what we're going to
do. All right, so again,
a hundred apologies if you've ordered,
you know, if you're ordering now,
it was restocked at a higher quality
shirt and I apologize and we will make it
up to you and we won't do anything
like that again. There's that.
Um, are you ready to go? Yeah. Your
mom's house, podcast.com. Click on it.
Shop around. Check it out.
Come see a show. We love you.
We'll see you next week.
Buy Jeans.
I slotting jobs,
jobs.
I heard her say a word that I know
is distinctly on parliamentary.
Mark.
Nobody wants to talk about pardon?
What is it like,
you know what I'm saying?
Whoops. Hot, hot,
sloppy.
Joe's
hot bark. Bark, bark, bark,
bark, bark, bark, bark.
Jason's Jason's sure. Jason,
Jason,
Jason.